the question under us was what do I need
to prove this okay do we need to prove
this and the answer is kind of because
these results here just like with the
parametric's of the parabola la casa
parabola much a frustration these are
not credible results okay we can't just
simply go there and then substitute it
and then go home okay that's a bit of a
shame however knowing these well will
allow us to check out and some very
quickly and very efficiently once we go
through kind of a semi Cartesian
approach you'll see how these kind of
mix together watch this is a typical
question admittedly this is not the way
it's sweated it would be waited much
longer
there'll be an ellipse represented by x
equals 4 cos theta y equals two sine
theta and what they want to know is what
is the equation of the tangent for this
particular value of P okay so again
think back what I need is kind of three
pieces for a tangent right I need an x
coordinate I need a Y corner and I need
a gradient right I need one 9 12 and
experts okay so let's do the easy bits
first let's work out x and y so when
theta is playing for X is equal to now
it's cause of platform because of PO 4
is 1 over root 2 so I'm gonna get 4 on
root 2 and I think you could probably
simplify that in your head that's 2 -
okay four-on-two okay with that I in the
same way when I have a look at why I'm
gonna get 2 times community a plus 100 -
200 - is just I've got some quarters now
I need a gradient right so therefore
what I've got to say is well do Y on
eggs right I need to know what this is
is going to be just go back to this idea
again is this chain rule right so what
do you want
sorry yeah what do you want Athena there
it is I start with two sine theta sine
differentiate into colors right so this
is just gonna be two cause it up and
then I'm gonna multiply by the
reciprocal of this derivative which is
cos differentiates into by this sign so
this is going to be minus 4 sine yep
okay so let's just tie this up a little
bit cancel cancel so this is gonna be
minus 1 over 2 times cos theta on sine
theta does that look okay yeah and now
they hate anything about this but the
reason why I can turn that to cot for
instance is because I'm already go onto
the effort of working out what causes
sign up and conveniently for me when
theta equals PI on for cousins
sign exactly equal yes so therefore when
theta equals platform the derivative is
does that make sense it's negative 1/2
times 1 great there are all my pieces so
now I just need to pop them into port
gradient for write y minus y1 because
and minus 1/2 times X minus x1 no no it
was it and the reason why is because I
have known this numbers are
categorically easier to do it then all
of this algebra is not right sir hi I
guess I just tidy this up general form
we might as well cuz it you kind of
every symptom of that when you grow up
in a numbers here I'm gonna multiply
through by 2 probably would you do me
this
does that look okay does that look okay
Spanish and then I'll just get
everything over here x + 2 y - 4 -
that's keys so you can see I could just
go check here but let's just check it
with it what with what this just let's
just confirm it okay X plus V done here
it is right is X that's x 1 on drew -
yes
what's a in this case yes right there
plus y times cos theta which is again
everybody 102 all - and I read that off
here yep that all equals to 1 what would
you like me to multiply Q by right so
now we'll just turn this into X 1 over
root 2 this will turn this into 2 y 102
equals 1 and then I want to get rid of a
blue - as well as oh no right so I
multiply everything through by root 2
which gives me X plus 2y and while I'm
at it I might as well bring this back
over minus 4 root 2 and their life